you've got very positive thoughts from
what i understand around bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies maybe talk a little bit
just how you see that part of the
industry as a lot of the folks who are
watching this and listening to it they
probably have too much of their net
worth invested uh in that sector of of
the financial world but how do you look
at bitcoin and crypto yeah it is part of
my portfolio and from a sofi standpoint
you know we always start with a member
and what they want so when we were
launching sofi invest i challenged the
team to offer beyond auto investing the
team wanted to launch us with robo
advisory accounts and we we didn't offer
robo accounts we still have them in fact
one of our robo accounts was just named
the best performing robo account by
barons but we did a survey of our
members and we asked them what assets
would they want and sure enough
cryptocurrency was on the list as number
three
we launched the product originally with
robo accounts also single stocks without
commissions and we started to see our
members buying ford and ge and i
couldn't figure out why our audience
which is millennial and gen z is buying
ford and ge like they're not that
exciting i think they're not great
growth stories and sure enough they were
both less than ten dollars and that was
our inspiration to launch fractional
shares we're like our investors are new
they're trying to figure it out they
want to diversify so we launched
fractional shares others have copied us
but we were the first then we introduced
a bunch of etfs that are very
diversified so we have six etfs some
that are at 10 price points that have
500 stocks they're broadly diversified
some that are thematic like the gig
economy uh etf um and then after doing
that we introduced cryptocurrency so on
the platform we initially launched uh
bitcoin litecoin and ethereum we've now
added 21 uh new coins on the back of
that and today i think we're adding
another six as of this morning it's it's
slowly running out to members um i
believe in bitcoin as an asset it's
highly risky um it's subject to
regulation it's subject to a bunch of
externalities that could impair it but i
believe that investing in in bitcoin is
an opportunity to invest in a technology
that is going to continue to evolve and
then be industrialized and
commercialized over the next 30 years
just as the internet was back back in
the 90s but it is highly volatile every
time someone buys cryptocurrency on our
platform we give them a warning that
says this is an unproven asset you can
lose all of your money about 10 to 15 of
my net wealth is in liquid net wealth is
in in cryptocurrency and um i just
dollar cost average into it every week
if you go on the app sofi app and you
follow me you'll see that each week i
buy a little bitcoin i buy a little
ethereum i buy a little doge i recently
added a couple others that you'll see
there
so when you just said 10 to 15 percent
of your liquid portfolios in bitcoin
cryptocurrencies my brother who's here
with me looked over at me and his
eyeballs almost fell out of his head uh
walk through a little bit um in terms of
how you think of portfolio construction
in general so you got 10 to 15 crypto
how do you think about the the rest of
the portfolio and why in some people's
eyes 10 to 15 is a high percentage in
the crypto world you know people say hey
why so bearish and and think of it as a
small percentage you know when i when i
started buying um bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies um it was about five
percent but the you know fortunately i
bought
very early and i continued to buy and
that's how it got up to the 10 to 15
um i i kind of think about it this way
um a lot of my compensation and my net
wealth is in sofi stock which um i'm a
long-term believer in and so the
liquidity there is going to be very
limited and so i need to diversify away
from that and i'm diversifying to other
asset classes
so i have a lot of consumer holdings
it's probably 20 to 25
of my holdings and then technology
stocks through diversified ets are are
the net next significant portion and
cryptocurrency would be last i generally
use etfs to express my point of view in
investing so for example i own the sofa
gig economy etf i want to own those
companies that are leveraging
this gig economy
to drive value i also own big tech and
so i have some blue chip tech technology
companies uh through a etf called pnqi
um and i also want some exposure to just
indexing the market with a little
leverage so i have a little sso and a
little spxl one is sso's a double
levered long s p 500 sp xl is a triple
long s p 500 those are smaller positions
um but that gives me broad-based index
exposure so i i drive my differentiated
return through that portfolio
construction some highly volatile
unproven high bit of stuff uh some stuff
that i know really well technology and
then some stuff that's going to benefit
from brighter innovation in the in the
consumer sector and direct to consumer
not necessarily technology
awesome i think that's a really
descriptive way to kind of walk through
it what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]